[Applaus]
[Musik]
kein Traumhaus ein traumturm der Denkmal
geschützte Wasserturm in kuckshafen an
der Nordsee ihn zu renovieren und
auszubauen das ist die Vision es war
natürlich witzig wenn wir jetzt da drin
könte Kaffee Bau oder ja das ist das ist
schon Schw Millionen Projekt
was sich Familie kabusa aus dem emal
nicht hat träumen
[Musik]
lassen wie viel Mühe Nerven Jahre und
Geld Sie dieses Projekt kosten
wird
aber wir müssen vorwärts machen es geht
auch um die Baugenehmigung
der Turm verlangt den Auswanderern alles
[Musik]
ab
gut ja
sch nach piss ja piss ja R oder we und
das sp ich muss da
s das ist doch grusig zum schießen und
denk zu es ist mai
2023 eine Flut von kleinen und großen
Problemen Zert an all und Mirabel kabuss
Nerven mach
sooation natürlich
h
ja
neation jaürlich
aber der stillgelegte Wasserturm 6 Jahre
nach dem Kauf ist er immer noch eine
große Baustelle die Eröffnung zögert
sich eins ums andere Mal
hinaus
[Musik]
die Besitzer packen wenn immer möglich
selbst
[Musik]
an bis ins Detail behalten sie alles im
Auge
unbeirbar klar also
eh
m was machen wir hier
aber so viel
m B und hab und D Hal das jetzt schade
blöd war wenn wir jetzt sagen ja jetzt
jetzt hab gesehen jetzt sind wir viel
viel wieder stärker positiver aber ich
irendwn gar nicht mer also ich habich
schon
Sch
5 Jahre zuvor in Langnau im Emmental
packen die kabusas ihre Sachen ihr
einfilienhaus haben sie verkauft ein
voller Lastwagen das ist die ganze habe
die sie mit ins neue Leben
nehmen vorwärts
machen K
nichtehmen soll in kushfen die
obligatorische schulit
sein terer bruderol wird eine Lehrstelle
suchen länger und darum bin
ich los geht fast 1000 km
nordwärts ans
warten hier inen
haben gemietet vier Zimmer es wird enger
als in der
Heimat hier
istübergangslig
derlichkeit
und die Stadt kuckshafen ist ein
Tourismusmagnet
8 Millionen Tagesgäste kommen jedes Jahr
in die Region der Wasserturm der 2004
stillgelegt wurde soll bald als neue
Attraktion wieder
erstrahlen aber zuerst muss die Familie
in den Alltag
finden der erste Schultag hoffe wirklich
das Beste für dass sie gute die Freunde
fingen g die Lehrer und das ist der
richtig integriere das ist
im
Moment ganz
sicher und
die
e
Wasserturm Lokaltermin mit dem
Architektenteam aus
Hamburg sind schon ein bisschen klar
geworden fenst gab haben große
Pläne
geh Zimmer im drit Stock ferieenwoh und
gab nach Kaffee vi
geh eine Wohnung für die ganze Familie
das ist der
Traum die Machbarkeit des Umbaus haben
all und Mirabel
kabusa vor dem Kauf geprüft sie gehen
gut vorbereitet in das
Abenteuer
Wassertank 12
m der Tank groß wie ein
Einfamilienhaus hier hoch oben im Turm
soll das Kaffee entstehen ja das
ist was macht Zukunft
ganz
dies Jahr wird geplant und nächstes Jahr
begin lange das dann braucht muss man
dann
schauen
schau das nicht noch Plan das ist
ein Mirabel soll recht
behalten schon bald ist die gelernte
Buchbinderin mitten im baustress per
Mail ist ein Angebot für den Einbau
eines Lifts
gekommen
es machbar
ist
und dann verschiedene Brandschutz Sache
fragf rechtwendig bis zum
Z all ist der weil zurück in Bern bis
der Gästebetrieb im Turm läuft zählt die
Familie auf seinen Verdienst aus dem
früheren
Job
so als messeleiter behält er alles im
Blick
so geht sehr viel Geld
und das müssen perfekt
machen nach diesem Mandat willaba als
Freelancer im messerbaaueld verdienen so
der
Plan minut Minute
gut das Projekt waserturm immer noch in
der
Bewilligungsphase ein Jahr ist seit der
Ankunft vergangen wegen des Kaffes oben
im Wassertank sind noch immer viele
Fragen offen der Turm ist zu hoch zu
hoch für die Leiter der
feuerweh Warte vi zu der bricht vom
Brandschutz es genau geht wo das Gebäude
sehr komplex für
Brandschutz das ist Ding und
vor und schutzr machen und Überdruck
ste
passieren das Kernen übernehmen sie
selbst
vorwärs ma das M
nicht Zögerung
zermürbt wir müssen vorwärts machen es
geht auch um die Baugenehmigung die
müssen wir
einreichen nichts geht mehr auch bei
aller wegen der coronakrise wurde eine
geplante Messe abgesagt ja das Problem
ist einfach das ist finanziell gar nicht
mehr
möglich aber aber
kstof ja
günstiger
men Monate gehen ins
[Musik]
Land Monate mit neuen Auflagen und neuen
Anforderungen das da demoliert ist Teil
oder gut m machen V Material das geht
Analyse Bomben weleg
die Sachen und das ist jetzt nicht der
Fall aber daset natürlich
ausab suchen
Hilfe Hallo guten
Morgen kleines die
Kaffeepause dam noch von der Schweiz
haben genau beim neugewählten
Oberbürgermeister von
kuckshafen wir sind ganz froh dass sie
da sind und dass sie sozusagen mit ihrer
Initiative diesen Wasserturm noch
mal zum Leben erwecken die Holzfenster
Kosten über 65 000 € mehr als die
Kunststofffenster das Dach muss man
schauen das Geländer innen wir wir
können uns das einfach nicht alles
leisten das das können wir
nachvollziehen da gab's ja ein einen
ersten Impuls auch von der
Wirtschaftsförderung das werden wir noch
mal angehen bei den Fenstern wird
bleiben aber wir können gucken ob wir
mit mit dem einen oder anderen
Fördertopf es hinkriegen dass ihre
Belastung irgendwie zumutbar auch ist ne
ja wir brauchen einfach auch die
Unterstützung ohne geht das einfach
nicht das ist so das die Hoffnung auf
Subventionen zerschlägt sich
bald
le
das und ja fre dass man dass man das
Projekt macht od das
[Musik]
Vers das Hauptprojekt steht still es
braucht neue
Geschäftsideen kabusas eröffnen ein
rollendes Kaffee mit dem sie Märkte
besuchen
Cappuccino den alten citroin haben sie
eigens umbauen lassen der Kaffee ist
gefragt heute sind sie für einen
Firmenanlass
gebucht schön so super läuft
aber am
und ja
das aber sch gut also stimmt für schon
so jetzt R
aber sch
fr genau wir hoffen nächstes Jahr zu
eröffnen ja das muss sein ist der
Spaßfaktor dann irgendwan mal zu Ende
das ist untertrieben Geldsorgen treiben
kabusas
um tchüs jeder Euro ist
willkommen
möglich dass
daer oder zpart denkt für
Wasser der jüere deriden S ist im
letzten Schuljahr und möchte eine
Ausbildung zum Forstwart
beginnenü Nicola beendet bald seine
Ausbildung zum
Hotelfachmann ma ein schwi Zurück
Militär machen D s das mal
gemacht und ja mal wi
Jake und das ist
ing ma zur
cool
der Ding
und über d Jahre lang versuchen die
kabusas alles um ihren ursprünglichen
Plan umzusetzen
vergeblich deroe traumchlgt
sich sie einen tiefgreifenden
Entscheid ja sch sie werden Ihr Projekt
radikal verkleinern es wird kein Kaffee
im Wassertank geben hoch über der Stadt
die ulage V Brandschutz hochus
Richtlinie s so enorm Worte und und
aufwendig dass
manfachf müss da eine andere lösen und
das bedeutet dass mir jetzt
und nacher geht sie erste obergesch war
die erste ferieen wohn Z obgeschoss Z
und die dritte ferieenwohn ist der
ungerhb vom Technik Bereich vom Tisch
ist auch der Traum von der eigenen
Wohnung im Turm schon bald werden sie
das redimensionierte Baugesuch
einreichen es wird im Sommer 2021 gut
geheißen endlich kann es losgehen die
Bauarbeiten beginnen
außen
sch
[Musik]
geh Z Jahre
später
gut die treappe muss ich hier also
provisorisch machen ja
ja ich
probi noch immer ist der Turm eine
Baustelle Handwerker zu bekommen eine
glückssach
schat ja es kom nicht mal
h
ja die H
ist
gut da schon ausgespachtelt ausesach
fertigachtelt ti to kom die Kante da und
im Inneren sind die Arbeiten langsam in
Gang gekommen okay und jetzt müssen wir
den und das
Glas das ist das für Schlafzimmer
ja das Glas hier muss
Glas
Schlafzimmer
hierörper di schwitz rund
extra gebogen für da was wir das wieder
was wir und schönste ist ganze stimmt
was ich g da bin ich sehr ST das macht
natürlich jetzt Fr
Optis und das ist das wo man Lang Lang
Lang
nichth und das aber es ist muss Abau
richtig
aufbauen jetzt müssen wir das
roh unbedingt
nochich Problematik
unglaublich für 36 m Strich und Z das
muss Brandschutz spezialfarb s mehrere
Schichten und wenn ich
waslage für Brandschutz auch detektier
schon Sache Ries Sache wahnsinnig Dur
und trotzdem müssen das im noch machen
das ist das wo nicht so viel
Verständnis in den Ferienwohnungen tut
sich etwas
wir haben gerade ihr Werk bestand das
sieht super gut aus
hallo wir sind zufrieden sehr zufrieden
und das passt wirklich auch zu den
Wänden
zu zu den Steinen an der Wand also
wirlich wirklich gut
[Musik]
soerm S auf gutem
Weg ein günstiger Moment für einen
Abstecher in die
Schweiz Sohn Janis hat seine Pläne
geändert nicht
Forstwart bckerkonditor will erlernen
und zwar hier im zircher Unterland ist B
Herr B nicht hier ja ich will
schnell g morgen grü guten Morgen
wir wirklich kein Schmuck
also in der Bäckerei Fleischli hat der
20jährige bereits geschnuppert beide
Seiten waren zufrieden erste
Schritt das
WPL das W jetzt da z. der tpfr das
früher ja 2 Uhr Start ja ja Schlaf Stund
das wirklich
einfach mit also das ist einfach so der
[Musik]
ty ich weiß nicht
n ich
muss muss machen nicht nuranden oder das
fre natürlich extrem sehr sehr
g
est
n zur
Arbeit ma
das es hei Abschied
nehmen ging es nach mirab und wäre der
Wasserturm schon längst fertig umgebaut
stattdessen ist jetzt eine Art
Voreröffnung im Außenbereich
geplant
heute wie viel D man gut vorbereit das
ist kom immer wieder zü
sind ist
viel und jetzt muss ich noch
mal
das
Hand das passiert
öfter minut ich das ist ti sehr gut das
ist das
irg genau ja passt einfach
ist
belasentsigung m
wirk hat wir da das ging wirklich
schlecht weg nicht aber es funktioniert
zum Glück bis jetzt so hallo
Schatz bald wollen sie erstmals Gäste
empfangen es bleibt nur noch ein Tag für
die
Vorbereitung ich bin sehr gespannt wie
das alsoag Gut g
ja wer überenn
oder
ein
Schag auf ja ich gut
geh seit ihr Alter Citro den Dienst
versagt hat sind die beiden mit einem
neuen kaffemobil unterwegs aber auch
dieses Gefährt ist mittlerweile nicht
mehr
fahrtüchtig die mE die
Frau
es ist ein Samstag im Mai
2023 am son Blumenmarkt
und auchfragt
worden vom event manager me ger W
ja und jetzt sind wir einach
Terrasse und m D jetzt sais mitnmen wir
juni wer so wie den aus W noch mehr
verselt wden geht es gut viel passiert
und
zum mit der Handwerk Problem aber mit
der
Material mit die Pandemie und oder Krieg
und aus das H
so ja verzerig allgemein
und schlimm ist aber einfach dass die
Handwerker viel versprochen und
die im Wasserturm steckt das ganze
private Vermögen auch der Erlös aus dem
Verkauf des Einfamilienhauses in der
Schweiz dazu ein Bankkredit und private
Darlehen und doch wird es
knapp
wahnsinnig
schwierigegang der Sparkasse oder so
worden mit de
Zins g und
geht zuus im immer ausgab od das
ist es geht ja
aus mit den
Stein Spenden noch setzen aber Tropf
h halloentschuldigung wissen auch nicht
WN das öffn
nein das steht noch in den
Sternen nein am Morgen ist hier außen
geöffnet und innen dann vielleicht ab
Juli was hab wir jetzt für
z aber l
ich handtier mit dem Strom aber das geht
do nicht ist s das vorher müssen machen
ja aber du h sch nicht also irgend ja
nicht
spmer da die F mit gabusas sind
erschöpft seit Jahren ist der Druck
konstant
hoch hallo so Streuobst l Kräuter
Holunder
Zitrone sehr
gut
im 150 vi Nummer
60 2
guten Start kann schön schief gehen
schönen Tag danke
tschüssunkel
Fräse und bisschen verschiedenes Beiwerk
ne ein bisschen Eukalyptus Schleierkraut
ich finde so ein bisschen greenbell noch
ganz nett das macht das so ein bisschen
das ist do gut aber ganz kuckshafen ist
glaube ich gespannt dass endlich
eröffnet das ist doch gut gut hat ja
auch lange gedauert ja ja gut es ist
erst außen innen ist ja noch nicht
am Sonntag mal vorbeisauen wunderbar
sehr schön war sch gespanntf sie war
vielle ist
aber Start das wir zeigen wie ich muss V
od
Schatz die Kaffeemaschine kommt frisch
aus dem Service
zurück Gott das der geht nein es
funktioniert nicht das Problem ist jetzt
ist ja schon warm und jetzt kommt der
Dampf Dampf
und Spin od Stampf Dampf Dampf
komamp aber verruckt K die
Technik
650€ ev
Mirabell suchtrat beim Hersteller
schriftlich schau mal
selber mit ganz Z nicht sber von aber
das
wenig ja ja hallo moin wir haben da ein
bisschen ein Problem vielleicht kannst
du uns helfen mal schauen ich drehe mal
die Kamera und dann sprich mein Mann
dazuchuldigung so so sehr gut
also jetzt machen könntet an den Griff
den kann man abschrauben
ja gut dann kann man den rausnehmen
war so und das geht dann in drinne geht
das auf den Stösel drauf aber ich habe
nicht die richtiges Werkzeug für das wir
haben ja das die Revision bezahlt wir
kann ich ja nicht noch mal den Service
machen hier ich nein das geht nicht das
muss jemand das Problem ist wir haben
noch so viel zu tun bis morgen und uns
läuft die Zeit davon das geht nicht das
bewegt es bewegt sich zwar da
funktioniert gar nichts ja was ist die
Lösung
jetzt also die Lösung wäre jetzt einfach
die stüsel zu machen ja ja aber der geht
nicht sonst würde ich do gerne machen
das und das ich habe jetzt abgestellt
weil sonst kommt nur noch
Dampf stimmt irgendwas nicht jetzt ist
sie runtergefallen jetzt habe ich sie
nicht mehr Scheiße nein das muss jemand
kommen fertig und wir haben ich hab ich
habe Wochenende das Problem also da muss
eine Lösung h wirklich ja gut
mor kabusas können nur hoffen dass sich
der Techniker auf den Weg
[Musik]
macht um 4:30 Uhr schließlich trifft er
ein sehr gesprächig ist er allerdings
nicht du mit drücke
ah jetzt aber innen drin
ist hast Du dem gesagt Stösel der Stösel
war ganz krum ganz gebogen wie auch
immer warum das passiert ist dann geht
es schnell da bin
ich es dampft genau wie es dampfen
soll tschüss
[Musik]
danke
der große Tag der außeneröffnung eine
Freundin hilft hallo oh wie geht dir
noch eineinhalb Stunden bis zum Start
ich fre mich eiglich soll die ganz
ruhig das ist wenn man a perfekt ma und
weiß es ist noch nicht
perfekt n nicht nicht me Stress das
bringt gar nicht
sch
schön Doppel du brauch
das und gut
sch ja es geht gleich
los ich
durch das
wir
schatz was schz mus das geht du mus
F kann ich
machen wie
schatzessopresso
schon gut sch gut sch gut kein Problem
geht aber gerade so nee ne nicht er
müsste wo hat mein
Verlängerungskabel hat das hingetan
jetztut
da
morgenit
so sisch und und einfach
nicht das mach mir ganz die
FU schat es tut mir leid das ich
nicht müssen ja ich weiß we aber jetzt
mus um Punkt 11 geht es los was hätten
Sie gerne ein Espresso Espresso
oder ein ich habe auch Filterkaffee
diesmal wie sie wollen ein Filterkaffee
gerne schatz was für bestellig gar
espressoesso mus
ich der
kommt bald steht fest das Kaffee vor dem
Wasserturm ist eine willkommene
Attraktion an diesem Markttag das ganz
ganz ganz toll wunderbar
aber schwierig zu
organisieren bisschen
schokoladenpulverucaucin
chtisch praktisch nicht
geschlaf
und ja mE nicht machen Sie sie haben
sich noch nicht hinten angestellt doch
ich habe mich da hinten angestellt weil
ich dachte ich kann das hier bezahlen
den nein hier ist keine Kasse die Kasse
ist nur da ich das bei ih bezahlen ja
machen wir jetzt so was gemacht haben ne
komm aus der Schweiz her mit dem eigenen
Geld machen das Ding hier fertig wieder
das
Wahrzeichen super und H wieder 100 Jahre
was hingekriegt hat machen die hier
haben sie drin auch schon auf noch nicht
ne nein nein nein wir testen mal ob sie
drauf funktioniert draußen ja okay dann
drü ich ih jetzt draußen die Daumen also
ich glaub es funktioniert sie werden
erwartet die Schlange wird nicht kürzer
die Stunden
verstreichen vielen
Dank ja genau mal nur gläse das ist ganz
gut meine Freundin wet auf ihren
Cappuccino und in der Zeit werde ich
mich einfach ein bisschen nützlich
zeigen so ein wenn jeder was tut dann
klappt auch weil die Leute wen ja leider
Gott halbe Stunde auf Kaffee ne weil die
einfach zu wenig Leute haben esft also
unglaublich was da abgeht das
Entscheidig danke
viels tschüss C danke
tschüss kuckshafen hat die Schweizer
Auswanderer ins Herz geschlossen die
Anteilnahme überwältigt
merabel
es ist
quautig so
schön in Start macht sich Nikola gabusa
bereit für den
Arbeitstag
niikola macht der hauptservice auf
Terrasse und hier
innen nach der Ausbildung in Deutschland
arbeitet er in einem vier Sterne Hotel
in der alten
Heimat er fühlt sich in der Schweiz
wohler als in
Deutschland die Nord direk
schwi vi das
[Musik]
falsch
also vorem Nord und D natürlich SP
anders und das ist sch die Kultur
W die
rechte
g langsam fertig endlich nach 5 Jahr
ist dass das mal
fertig
auf ser ger
wunderbar trotz aller Rückschläge
niikola hat volles Vertrauen dass der
Turm bald eröffnet
wird ja zuversichtlich ja muss
sie w S und sie sag das machen WE 100%
und dann klapp das so das ist immer
so zft im so B auch Nikola zieht seine
Pläne durch schon bald wird er die RS
antreten die Mietwohnung in kuckshafen
vom vermeintlichen Provisorium zur
Dauerlösung die Eltern haben ihr Büro im
früheren Kinderzimmer eingerichtet
die aber zum Anger geht so wieder bchen
Luft sage
gich mir
ja Koch
wennus und hab jetzt noch auf ganze
konzentriere was der Wasser betrifft
gabusas sind Eigentümer und Bauleitung
in
einem du nur irgendwelche
prisvergünstigung ja warte
alle Rabatt
5€ ja super
5€ nach dem Abenteuer mit der
außeneröffnung richtet sich der Fokus
wieder auf den
Innenausbau noch also die wir die
wir und die da das gemacht Word das muss
jetztzien wenn das gell
vor die Sachen wirklich so fertig und
das haut fertig das ist so da im Kaffee
also n ganz Kaff mit 20 24 Platz
aber schön hallo
Hall sehr
gut
sch Jacht was mirft passiert
oh mus
jamaschine
und
bring SP odmaschine
ichf die ganze
Zeit eig ich ma sehr gerne B und all
aber jetzt hab wir Wochenend auf der R
Terrasse geöffnet schön ein mit der G
und Kontakt mit der L das ist mir
wichtig es sieht danach aus als wären
kabusas auf der
Zielgeraden hier sollen bald die ersten
Feriengäste
einziehen hier Wasser das nicht
gut sch machen sie m überprüfen mus
jetzt mal
F
Problem die Problem das wir mir sehr
belasten wieder
mal R highlightusen ist am
Anfang das ist so schlimm g und jedes
Mal ist Problem g D Wasser so drüber
immer die W od nicht Strich oder so das
ist
schus gut bis jetzt das ist nicht
gut ist nicht
gut
scheiße das dar mir nicht
ja guten Tag Herr köer hier istus vom
Wasserturm und da sehe ich jetzt
Wasser wieder beim Fenster wenn sie dann
kommen wäre ich dann froh sie das noch
mal alles überprüfen ob das wirklich ein
größeres Problem wieder ist bei diesem
Fenster son
K Wind und Wetter zerren am Turm Runde
wendee
hohe Räume hier gibt es keine
Standardlösungen die Eröffnung im Sommer
war ein
[Musik]
Wunschtraum
mus aber jetzt sind die drei
Ferienwohnungen
fertig oder zumindest fast
fertig sehr
gut ja wirklich
auf
vor
Mon se
neit
sch
SPR
das
sch
schaff
wür für
250en na S metet werden aber ganz
ausgestanden ist der Ausbau noch
nicht noch
nicht
jah
vorhänger der Strom von Aufgaben will
nicht
abreißenil
genau der B muss ich dann noch machen da
muss ich no hier
polieren gar nicht so das ist mir fre
extrem für Kaffee mir fre dasus
geschafft aber das ist einach schon
Batterie schon
langsam Kampf komplette Kampf mit dem
hat d es wir so muss drum das überhaupt
so
wie
ja
l fertig
machen ich muss unbedingt
unbedingt ausruhen können Sie noch nicht
heute gibt es den ersten Anlass im
Wasserturm Caffé als Dankeschön haben
Mirabel und alla rund 30 Freundinnen und
Freunde
eingeladen ja
[Musik]
sehr so Nikola ist eigens aus der
Unteroffiziersschule
angereist die
gan nicht
Küst
[Gelächter]
Küst hallo Benny ihr seid die ersten
hereinpaziertes
gute hallo hallo
hallo geht
einfach ja danke schön
ja herzlichen
glückwch danke
schön
Zitron was ma
mit oder wen
ma vi da
trinken ja eigentlich muss man und
trinken ja mach das S das machen ja mach
das was darf ich anbieten wir haben ja
alles
mögliche versten
hallo vi vien
dan danke schön
ja
Cappuccino sehr gerne
also ja ja erstenmals ganz herzlichen
und lieben lieben Dank dass ihr alle
gekommen seid also es freut uns
unglaublich ich bin im Moment in einem
Wechselbad von 1us Gefühlen die durch
meinen Körper strömen von Freude und und
und und auch müde und durch all diese
Zeiten aber den wichtigsten Menschen an
meiner Seite das ist alle und der hat
mich aufgebaut wenn es mir nicht gut
ging wenn ich mal wieder mehr schwarz
als irg eine andere Farbe gesehen habe
und was er hier geleistet hat das ist
schon fast unmenschlich
und dafür danke ich Dir von ganzem
Herzen
ich habe nicht gedacht dass Mirabella
eine steuerexpertin eine
mehrwertsteuerexpertin eine Anwältin und
alles mögliche wird nur um das vorwärts
zu treiben und wir haben uns habe ich
sehr gut sehr gut ergänzt und jetzt
wollen wir Euch einladen weil wir
einfach gesagt haben ihr seid uns sehr
wichtig weil ja auch diese Zeit immer
wieder besucht und uns unterstützt habt
das ist sehr sehr toll und das fre uns
außerordentlich wir gehen mal eine
ferenwohnung anschauen wie das etwa
aussehen könnte einfach mit mir kommen
se Personen die Lust und Laune gerade
haben geh
mal also jetzt habe ich KT ein bisschen
Ben weil ich noch gerade eingewachst
habe
mega
ich seit fast war der Wasserturm
geschlossen die Einheimischen sehen das
Wahrzeichen der Stadt zum ersten Mal von
innen das war alles war schon eine
Wohnung aber die war ganz anders al die
hatte kein Durchgang wir haben es alles
wieder geöffnet da war war alles zu an
kleine Räume teilweise mussten wir Wände
fortnehmen ich lieb die Heizkörper die
Heizkörper haben wir extra herstellen
lassen das ist von der in der Schweiz
die sind alle gerundet darf gar nicht
sagen was kostet das Ding
oh das ist dasmental dort wo mirab und
ich lange gewohnt
haben ja könnte man aber das haben wir
nicht
eingericht sehr gut ja
ja
genau ja e Lebensaufgabe und das ist
fast BTE etc sag ja aber im Endeffekt
ist das Projekt das F und es geht das
Handy aber mit Würde ger ma aber n und
dann machen wir so und BR zu
den TÜ
dankeönung tschüss
[Musik]
dan du aus im vus wü ich wenn wir jetzt
das
mirfah die S unbezahlbar das ist sehr
sehr
n
hallo
fre mir fre schön g sehr schön g jetzt
müssen
noch
[Musik]
schn